hey everyone
more and more individuals are becoming
interested in cryptocurrencies these
days from financial institutions to
everyday investors you'll need a crypto
exchange account to buy and sell digital
currencies like bitcoin ethereum
dogecoin to get it on the fun
so
here i am to take you through this new
video of simply learn on top crypto
trading platforms in 2022 to assist you
in selecting the best platforms for your
needs
we have looked through the most popular
platforms to find the finest crypto
trading platforms available right now
so let's get started with the video but
before moving ahead please do hit the
like button and click the subscribe
button for more interesting updates from
simply learn so let's have a look at the
top crypto trading platform in 2022 but
before diving right into the list let's
have a quick and crisp understanding of
what crypto trading actually means
so
taking a financial on the price
direction of individual cryptocurrencies
against the dollar or against any other
cryptocurrency is what crypto trading is
all about
cfds or contract for difference are a
popular weight of trading
cryptocurrencies because they offer more
flexibility leverage and the ability to
trade both long and short positions
also it's essential to consider things
like supported assets fees
payment methods and security when
considering a cryptocurrency trading
platform so we have also considered
these factors to give you a better idea
of which platform will be the best for
you so now that we have a basic idea
what crypto trading is let's dive into
the list of top crypto trading platforms
for 2022.
the first platform in the list is
coinbase
for many first-time cryptocurrency
buyers coinbase has become the go to
exchange the platform has the appearance
and feel of an online banking tool which
the majority of consumers are already
familiar with
making the transfer to crypto investing
simple
coinbase is the finest cryptocurrency
exchange overall as well as the best
cryptocurrency exchange for beginners it
supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrencies and provide a high
level of security
it's also wonderful alternative for
expert traders because it offers an
advanced trading platform coinbase pro
in addition to being a beginner-friendly
platform
so let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for coinbase
it supports more than 150 plus cryptos
for trading with the transaction fee
ranging between 0
to 0.60
also the minimum deposit of purchase
price should be at least two dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
coinbase offers a large volume of
cryptocurrencies
what to trade for it provides smooth
experience to beginners as well as offer
easy trading to advance members of it it
also provides liquidity and ease on its
platform
now cons
the customer service provided by them is
not up to the mark as well as
coinbase.com
is an institutional account which means
you don't have access to your private
keys
moving on next we have is crypto.com
crypto.com offers a diverse digital
asset ecosystem that includes is its own
blockchain the crypto.org
a native token known as cro
a crypto visa card yield generating
crypto products and more it was chosen
as the top mobile crypto exchange
application because it offers a
comprehensive digital asset trading and
investing environment that you can
access from your smartphone
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for crypto.com
it supports more than 250 plus cryptos
for trading with a transaction fee
ranging between 0.04 percent to 0.40
also the minimum deposit or purchase
price should be at least one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
crypto.com supports a huge range of
cryptocurrencies to trade for and other
crypto related services like payments
and asset
evaluation
now moving towards cons it fees is
relatively high also the customer
service is a little poor and stagnant
next in the list we have is gemini
gemini stands out as a sign that
prioritizes security and compliance
hot wallet insurance is provided by the
new york based exchange to ensure that
user funds are protected in the event of
a security comprise because it has
comprehensive security protocols ensures
customer cash and is soc two certified
gemini is the most secure crypto
exchange
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for gemini
it only supports 75 plus cryptos for
trading with the transaction fee ranging
between
0.99
to 2.99
also it has a minimum deposit
or purchase price and it varies
according to the asset invested
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
gemini is available in all 50 states of
united states with extremely liquid
market
all the funds stored in the wallets are
perfectly insured and secure also if ui
is pretty strong
coming to its cons
many traders in it have high cost also
as compared to other crypto trading
platforms it supports less
cryptocurrencies as well
now moving on to the next platform in
the list we have binance
the most appealing feature of binance is
it's low cost when compared
to other exchanges beginners will
appreciate the simple buy sell option
while professional traders will
appreciate the in-depth basic and
advanced trading platforms
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for binance it supports
more than 500 plus cryptos for trading
with a transaction fee ranging between
0.10 percent to 0.50
also it has no minimum deposit or
purchase price of 50
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
binance purchase piece is non-immediate
as well as instant also a huge variety
of coins is available on its platform
along with this it offers various other
services
coming to the cons once the verification
of account was hampered it is not yet
available in united states and its
corporate structure is pretty opaque
next we have is
kraken
kraken is one of the world's most
well-known bitcoin exchanges in the
early days of the crypto market it
established itself as the go-to site for
professional investors it has retained
its image as a trustworthy and
professional trading venue
it has some of the lowest fees in the
cryptocurrency exchange world it's also
our top pick for experienced traders as
it allows leverage and futures trading
as well as enables complex order types
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for kraken
basically it supports more than 120 plus
cryptos for trading with a small
transaction fee ranging between
0.00
to 0.26 percent
also it has minimum deposit or purchase
price of minimum one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
kraken supports a large range of
cryptocurrency with minimum fee and also
provide the traders more market
liquidity
coming to the cons not all states and us
can accept it
as options for financing your account
are limited
next in the list we have bitstamp
bitstamp is one of the most
cost-effective bitcoin exchanges it
offers a simple pricing structure
that bases your trading fees on your
30-day trading volume
for users with less than
ten thousand dollars on bitstamp the
highest trading cost is merely zero
point five zero percent bitstamp is a
fantastic alternative
for free conscious crypto investors
because its trading fees are lower than
those of many of its competitors
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
bitstamp offers only 45 cryptos for
trading with a very small transaction
fee ranging between 0.00
to 0.50
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 10
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
in terms of trading fees bitstamp is one
of the top cryptocurrency exchanges
tradeview a real-time trading platform
is also available this version contains
more extensive charting and trading
forms this platform offers a diverse
range of points including many of the
most popular as well as some lesser
known cryptos
and the cons are while bitstem offers a
good selection of cryptocurrencies there
are significant ones that aren't
available its bitstam make program which
allows you to stay crypto allows you to
earn passive money but there are a few
drawbacks as well in 2015 hackers were
successfully in launching office fishing
salt against bitstam workers which
resulted in a security breach
following bitstamp we have bitmap
bitmap is a global bitcoin exchange with
over 180 locations
users can purchase sell and store over
1000 different digital currencies and
tokens
investors wishing to add newly launched
or obscure crypto assets to the
portfolios while likely find what
they're searching for on this exchange
as it offers more assets and trading
pairs than its market leading
counterparts let's have a look at the
account prerequisites for bitmap bitmap
offers 1 000 cryptos for trading with a
very small transaction fee that ranges
between
0.045 percent to 0.25
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 30
when purchasing via bitmap
for spot trading the price is not
published yet
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
bitmap supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrency and provide great cr
opportunities to earn cryptocurrency as
well
along with that it provides an easy
trade option for buying and selling
cryptocurrencies
now moving on to the cons
there was a large scale hack on this
platform in 2021 also the customer
reviews are average for this application
moving on next in our list is cue coin
q coin is a third-party cryptocurrency
exchange that lets you buy sell and
trade a variety of cryptocurrencies
the founder's goal was to provide a
simple and secure platform for people
all around the world
to exchange a variety of digital
currency cue coin has a large number of
cryptocurrencies to choose from and has
minimal cost when compared to other
cryptocurrency exchanges
staking leverage futures and
peer-to-peer trading are all supported
which may appeal to more experienced
users
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for q coin
so q coin offers only up to 28 cryptos
for trading with a very small
transaction fee ranging between 0.00 to
0.10
also coming to its minimal deposit or
purchase the price is merely 5
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
cuecoin maintains the anonymity of the
user while trading yet it offers secured
platform as well also it supports
multiple cryptocurrencies
coming to the cons the trading volume of
cryptocurrencies are pretty low and also
during heavy traffic it can face some
serious issues
following q coin in our list we have
cash app
now individuals in the united states and
the united kingdom can use the cash app
to send spend deposit and invest money
it's an essentially a peer-to-peer
payment app with an investment component
through the cash app
users can also invest in stocks etfs and
bitcoin it enables you to purchase sell
and store bitcoin
from your smartphone itself in a more
simpler and safer manner
now
looking at its account prerequisites
like we discussed cash app is only a
bitcoin exchange application so it
supports only one cryptocurrency that is
bitcoin
the transaction fee varies depending on
the action
also the minimum deposit of purchase is
just one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
cash app provides an easy access ui and
quick withdrawal from its wallets
other than this it also supports bitcoin
lighting network it's a second layer
bitcoin technology that employs micro
payment channels to increase the
blockchain's ability to perform
transactions more quickly
moving on to the cons it only supports
bitcoin the wallet is always volunteered
and it has limits on everything be it
deposits sales and other items
so now we have reached a
last
crypto trading platform in our list
which is
bishk
bish is the peer-to-peer cryptocurrency
trading platform that allows individuals
from all over the world to trade a
variety of digital currencies and tokens
customers are not required to complete a
know your customer or kyc identity
verification process
and this trading platform is not
restricted to users in specific
jurisdictions
it lets users to buy and sell bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies with a
variety of payment options such as bank
wire transfers ach transfers and cash
deposits as well
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
bish currently supports 100 plus
cryptocurrencies for transaction with
transaction price ranging between 0.10
percent to 0.70
and there is no minimal deposit or
purchase required
now moving on to its pros and cons
this bish application is available
throughout the world and anyone can use
it
it provides a high-end security and
doesn't requires any sort of kyc or id
verification
and it provides almost 50 payment
options for crypto transactions
moving on to the cons the speed of the
transactions are pretty low and low
trading
values are also possible as it doesn't
consist of any minimal deposit or
purchase
also it is not a great option for active
trading
well this brings us to the end of this
video this was all about the top 10
crypto trading platforms for 2022. i
hope you enjoyed this video and learned
something new from it if you have any
questions regarding this information
please feel free to ask away in our
comment section
our experts will reach out to you as
soon as possible thank you and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here